most wanted man ist die verfilmung von
john le carrés driller marionetten die
regie führte der niederländer anton
corbijn du wirst was ich brauche das
gravitationszentrum des films ist der
kürzlich verstorbene schauspieler philip
seymour hoffman
er spielt günther bachmann den leiter
einer anti terror einheit in hamburg
bachmann scheut keine
auseinandersetzungen wieder mit dem
verfassungsschutz noch mit den
amerikanern richtige person die am
hauptbahnhof gesehen wurde
dazu wurde ihnen dieses handy foto
geschickt cup of china 26
man traut seinen jagdinstinkt anstatt
einen verdächtigen jungen tschetschenen
festzunehmen verdingt er den jungen mann
als köder um mit dessen hilfe ein
scheinbar unbedeutenden muslimischen
gelehrten zu überführen und was
beobachtet ihr john le carrés plot ist
makellos konstruiert dazu passt die
minimalistische umsetzung anton corbijns
als starrsinniger in die jahre gekommen
dass spion ist philip seymour hoffman
auf der höhe seines könnens
seine hartnäckigkeit wut hoffnung und
verzweiflung treiben den film voran auch
wenn bach man manchmal schwerfällig und
müde wirkt
was hält mich eigentlich davon ab diese
unterredung zu beenden
bedauerlich ist dass die übrigen
charaktere oft skizzenhaft wirken obwohl
sie hochkarätig besetzt sind von willem
defoe als bankier über robin wright als
amerikanischer agent in bis zu nina hoss
und daniel brühl als bachmanns
mitarbeiter oder herbert grönemeyer
als verbündeter
einen bericht erhalten ja konzentriere
ich vor allem auf burgdorf
innenministerium sich alle sehen mich an
uns an
aber wir existieren nicht rechtlich
nicht nicht offiziell weil die
geheimdienste in deutschland aufgaben
erfüllen müssen die mit dem gesetz und
vereinbar sind also am most wanted man
bildet zum teil etwas langatmig ab wie
die geheimdienste sich gegenseitig
belauern bis es zum showdown kommt
unsere quellen kommen nicht zu uns wir
finden sie selbst es ist ein glück dass
es diesen film gibt auch wenn er uns
allzu deutlich macht wie sehr uns philip
seymour hoffman jetzt schon fehlt wenn
wir sie am haken haben und nur dann
setzen wir sie auf größere ziele an man
braucht einen kleinen fisch um einen
barracuda zu fangen eine barracuda um
einen einzufangen